WWE Universe get ready to meet the next
great superstar yo you're gonna be late
all right kiddo time to get up
home ugh dad already Oh is our little
little it to be a WWE Superstar get that
back come on we're gonna get you Tom see
[Music]
well this math powers only work for
competitors who are deserving of its
magic
[Music]
what was that this mask makes me super
fast crazy strong I'm gonna break your
face nerd I think you should leave them
alone that was the coolest thing ever
the WWE is hosting a winner-take-all
tournament the winner will become the
next WWE superstar keep running keep
running keep running keep don't look
this guy's taking on that guy through
the chaos bro
just started are you so sweaty don't ask
questions you want answers to
gonna be easier than I thought I'm just
kidding good luck to none of youse
magical mask is not what makes you
strong real strap comes from here and
here
here comes Samson
[Music]
[Applause]
wow you're very hungry are you okay I
mean wearing a lot of colors
[Music]
you